[Música]
é muito tarde vamos falar exatamente de
uma nova tecnologia scliar utilizada no
material que já tem muito muito tempo
mas que nós não utilizamos exatamente
aquilo pelo qual não foi inventado
antes de começar só uma pequena história
um pelinho sobre a estratégia do nosso
território
nós sofremos na área dos materiais como
tal pelos diabos a utilização de
materiais abundantes e materiais não
tóxicos nos conteúdos que possuem esses
materiais temos que recuperar
tecnologias e também para as tecnologias
recorremos sempre tecnologias simples e
de baixa temperatura ou de baixa energia
bom é eletrônica é necessária uma
alternativa e já vão perceber porquê
portanto nós hoje em dia fazemos muito
aquilo que chama o lixo eletrônico esta
imagem está aqui aquilo que nós
produzimos todos os dias
esta não é a melhor forma de chegar até
nós reciclar um xixi eletrônica
produzimos todos os dias
esta também não é de tristeza e temos
que mudar a forma como deitamos fora
esta este lixo eletrônico
só para ter uma idéia este gráfico
mostra as rotas internacionais para onde
nós acabamos por deslocalizar este
problema e nome de um problema no
hemisfério norte portanto temos aqui
apresentadas as rotas internacionais
para onde está o lixo eletrônico é
transportado e vai exatamente para
países já na áfrica para a china e para
a índia
é evidente que isto não é sustentável
outra outro é muito grande que nós
enfrentamos fala do lixo eletrônico é
que o pn está muito na moda que os
microplásticos da poluição dos nossos
oceanos
esperamos que os plásticos têm só se
tentarmos como é que é possível que em
70 anos
exista ou esteja turística dentro de
poucos anos tenhamos mais plástico nos
oceanos
isso é também um exemplo nós chieira
esta é quantidade de plástico que é
deitada anualmente para os nossos
oceanos e que acaba por entrar na cadeia
alimentar e nós acabamos por comer e e
gerir este microplásticos e vamos falar
de uma alternativa não quer dizer que
isto seja um problema para todas as
funções é evidente que não é mas pelo
meu chope 700 pessoas que vão ficar
receberá pelo menos não ficasse
utilizadas para pequenas soluções e
talvez no nosso de areia possamos ter
uma atitude diferente daquela que temos
tido até agora vamos falar um bocadinho
de eletrônica da pele o que é isto
nós somos inspirados nossos cientistas e
um filme com julio verna com a repórter
por vezes estes filmes ao maior
interporto fazem nos pensar em coisas ou
em soluções que não existem que são
ficção científica mas que de alguma
forma se podem tornar fixa realidade e
realmente isso é possível portanto
aquilo que nós vimos há uns anos a esta
parte dos filmes de harry potter é
possível então por que eu fiz o da
aquisição de papel para aplicações de
eletrônica como se sabe é sula11 é um
material de origem renovável importante
existe não não polui quis falar mas até
hoje em dia fala-se muito em termos de
bioeconomia economia circular por tetê
neste panorama é extremamente importante
nós utilizamos materiais de origem
renovável importante suor se calhar ao
mesmo é um material que nós devemos
utilizar ou devemos prever o poder ao
poder utilizados para outras aplicações
que não só fazer papel fotocópia por
exemplo quando acionados para um mercado
ao para o mercado da indústria do papel
hoje em dia e apresentar uma tendência
destes mercados nem 12 do papel passarem
não só de norte para sul mas também não
utilizarmos papel só para
na sobra livre só vistas hoje em dia
temos uma série de coisas usar o pet
os ebooks e etc nós temos que pensar em
alternativas à utilização do papel chave
porque estamos na europa portanto temos
uma indústria papo era extremamente boa
aliás portugal e caso isso e temos que
reinventar porque o papel pode ter
nomeadamente as lojas têm muitas
aplicações que neste momento não nos
passa pela tereza bom é sua última série
de propriedades extremamente importante
e interessante tanto como eu já disse é
um betel biopolímeros extremamente
abundante é um material flexível e não
se parte portanto algumas aplicações já
existe e é extremamente importante e
admite eletrônica flexível o seu custo é
baixo
é um material muito leve para algumas
aplicações o piso extremamente
importante
a produção está x perfeitamente estamos
hidrogênio e admite que é de navegante é
tudo um espetáculo de fotocópia a uma
velocidade de 100 quilômetros por hora
portanto é tecnologia e isso não
precisamos de reinventar o papel
apresenta boas propriedades elétricas ou
slide tanto que eu saiba o papel não
conduz na sua famosa loose eletricidade
e do campo está em torno habitantes nós
quisemos utilizar o papel para outras
aplicações para produtos eletrônicos
xc60 do papel está em tudo até muito
mais fácil parece tecnologia quando o
papel quando a matéria-prima existe e
por último o material reciclado boi hoje
em dia também está na moda todo show vem
falar do grafeno aliás foi o primeiro do
prêmio nobel de física em 2010 e também
podemos fazer o que defendo é partir da
amazônia a partir das suas
isso é respeito das suas vistas ao
microscópio eletrônico se nós formos
observar do lado esquerdo temos uma
imagem de mitzpe eletrônica de um papel
normal papel fotocópia do lado direito
tem uma imagem também de celulose esta é
nosso los e temos aspectos não fugia são
muito parecidas temos uma rede nacional
de fibras de celulose e mixer ligam
daquela forma exatamente dar
sustentabilidade
neste caso tem mais mecânico o papel é
único
diferencia escala do lado esquerdo tem
100 mícrons e do lado direito tem 100
nomes e isto com cientista tem que ter
sempre alternativas
este é o aspecto de um papel do lado
direito com fibras de nove lojas e terá
ainda sido voz como nós a conhecemos que
extraída a partir da sars portanto da
madeira também é uma alternativa que
também é insustentável que utilizados
por exemplo não sei se sabem mas gignac
que tem umas bactérias chamam acertou
bactéria
isso parece algo da unita olharem com
uma garrafa vinagre não utilizarem
durante algum tempo por para combinar
que fica com umas coisinhas ficar bem
como as coisas esquisitas as cinturas
tanques em nosso los
portanto aquelas baterias em e produzem
nosso los com uma pureza muito elevada e
da origem um papel transparente
portanto nós também trabalhamos com
estes materiais para no caso eletrônica
e até se compararmos com ios por exemplo
eu se entende que uma pessoa não posso
crescer muito mais do que eu portanto
não é minha área mas chance nós fizemos
outras lojas a partir de origem vegetal
tem que deixar cheiro pinheiro eucalipto
quatro a cinco anos por carstens loss
se olhar uma garrafa de vinagre tanto
com esperar dois ou três dias e tem
folhas desse nosso los como as pessoas
similar à espessura do papel de
fotocópia tentar sempre alternativas só
aguardar alguns exemplos daquilo que nós
fazemos um laboratório utilizando
celulose micro celulose ou nosso loss
origem e instaladores de bacteriana nos
em 2008 inventamos pela primeira vez no
mundo transição do papel e história
portanto nunca ninguém tinha feito a
ciência foi ficar em portugal portanto
transístor de papel é português e que o
que fizemos foi muito simples e existe
uma tendência ainda hoje de substituir
um che que os jornais as revistas por
equipamentos eletrônicos fizemos a
substituição qualquer coisa mas sua voz
para um equipamento eletrônico é que o
que nós fizemos exatamente o contrário
nós queremos usar slogans como material
eletrônico não queremos deitar fora as
suas
o conteúdo susipe peixe nós como
trabalhamos um caminho contrário
passarmos o eda de idéias da esquerda
para a direita mpla própria cor evento
que eu sou do sporting mas não sabia
dizer mas paciência
acho muito triste este foi o primeiro
transístor de papel que é muito simples
basta fazer uma fotocópia frente e ver
se temos um desejo a tabela por um
consultor um semicondutor e agora
explorar essas coisas todas estão
aspectos transitórios ea espessura dos
materiais é tão fina que depois posso
escrever e possa imprimir mais coisas
sobre os nazistas sem problema nenhum
tem papel o condutor tenho-os existe é
só a gente não funciona eu tenho de os
integrar em terceiro com 8 integrados
daí ter este este circuito integrado sem
papel
além disso a gm chama as fotovoltaicas
chance começamos com os tetras o artista
deixa o tetra pak já tem parte tem um
novo mínimo no interior da embalagem que
todos os anos esse material metálico
como um dos elementos que constituem a
luz solar e também uma das aplicações de
toda esta área ser analisadas embalagens
inteligentes
outra área parte dos biossensores
nomeadamente texto dizia nós tics tanta
diretivas da organização mundial de
saúde
em termos testes de diagnóstico rápido
de baixo custo e possam ser usados por
toda a gente geralmente em regiões onde
não há nada ou não aplicar jorge quando
um hospital para fazer estas análises
específicas e somos hoje em dia o
diários de sessões nomeadamente 90% do
mercado que existe hoje em dia na área
de chicago não achei que para hélio
costa
mas é evidente que nós podemos ter a
popular não só paga o cosmo espera
outros biomarcadores e nós mais uma vez
pedro zerolo chupel utilizamos uma foto
com uma foto ap embora não ensinam uma
impressora a jacto a laser de ser neste
caso é da xerox e fazemos aquilo que
chama labonté importante nós fazemos
dispositivos à base de papel
começamos com direitos porque é
exatamente um problema em nível mundial
por outro lado o valor é o vaso tem aqui
um outro vídeo que se funcionar porque
temos aqui uma gotinha e chegou à
vitória com o qual sempre tenha de três
indicadores na parte de cima e
em uma resina a uma redução tenho uma
versão do opera numa item o indicador do
corpo em função da intensidade da cor eu
posso saber exatamente qual é a
concentração de glucose que tem podemos
pensar que podemos fazer coisas jamais e
evoluídas portanto temos vários projetos
recorrer nestas nossas áreas e depois
podemos desenvolver simplesmente uma
aplicação para telemóvel e em função das
retas ou curvas calibração podemos
reverter a mesma fotografia analisamos é
cor e seria exatamente qual é o valor só
em termos finais
este é um carinho nosso sonho é
desenvolver uma série de produtos danada
com base em eletrônica com base em
mostradores com base em biossensores à
base de tempo em que as lojas só
possível modificada pode ter um papel é
extremamente importante e isso não é
mais o que também é um trabalho de
equipe não gostaria de agradecer aqui
publicamente é este equipa e este time
português deve guardar chips morte e
deixar o shopping 12 minutos pesquisa
tem por verem o filme el cantor
universidade nova de lisboa em portugal
e exl e create future interno do país
o cliente nenhum eo técnico matjaz
eletronics muito convencional
electrónicos o iar face e meio de folga
numa sessão e acre disse o técnico vai
sendo ea export diploma toada parte
software iphone disse forsyth em cerca
de r 10 r 83 o evento e trânsito onde os
tios technologies também dengue pt for
conflict infantil
três despistes ao frango é photoshop
pequeno max semicondutores for low cost
eletrônica críticas chen flomo left to
the lights e quase piper equipe fugiu a
96 e tim vai para baiano electronic
components não foi assim taipei forte
eletrônica aplicação leva susto obtido
ecológica o produto
fui sair como o twitter e facebook
o starfish tafetá e em bicol piau bons
sites submete-los cantet nessa maracanã
e dom pedro ii plus é convencional mas
que o processo é feito com sul e que
news vai por forma a adaptar se queixem
da adaptar com aplicativos web onde
laura lima deixa de future que me saí
mal orcs e fecha a 18 em do im é nosso e
do im
[Música]
[Aplausos]